all right hello everyone
if you can't tell by my name everywhere
my name is Adam jar
I am co-founder and instructor over at V
mastery and this morning I want to
invite you all on an adventure who wants
to go on an adventure today okay awesome
most of you so we're going off deep into
space because our destination today is
the planet of beautopia somewhat like a
utopia but not quite so as we arrive on
the surface of the planet we are there
to explore and discover some secret
knowledge so as we navigate around the
planet we see these sacred secret
looking upside-down pyramid symbols so
we think we're on the right track and as
we continue exploring we see the temple
which we hear contains hidden knowledge
for us and as we approach we are greeted
with this barrier turns out we need to
have some sort of access granted to
receive this secret information so if
you haven't yet caught on this is a
elaborate analogy for my talk which is
about token-based authentication and in
this case we're doing it from scratch so
what is authentication for most of you
are aware there are often parts of your
application where you don't want just
everyone off the internet to be able to
access them so in that case we want to
be able to block those routes and have
only authenticated logged in users
access those parts of our application so
that is authentication and of course
there are different providers and
protocols when we're thought when we're
talking about authentication such as
auth oh firebase is another popular one
or you might be using OAuth where your
users are logging in with Google or
Facebook
or github something like that but today
this is from scratch so we're going to
look at creating our own solution using
JWT with local storage and we're gonna
focus solely on the view side we're at
view Amsterdam not know de Amsterdam or
Python Amsterdam so I'm gonna kind of
lightly touch on what considerations to
take on the server side but we're really
going to focus on the view portion so if
you're unfamiliar with JWT
it is an acronym standing for JSON web
tokens and you can think of this token
much like a key a key that unlocks those
blocked protected parts of your
application and the JWT consists of
three parts first it is the header which
tells you what type the token is in this
case it's going to be JWT
and then includes the hashing algorithm
being used and then secondly is the
payload so this contains the info that
we're transmitting information such as
the issuer of the token if it has an
expiration if the recipient of that
token has admin privileges things like
that go in the payload and then finally
we get to the signature which is a hash
of the header plus a payload plus a
secret so all of that together you've
got that token you got that key that you
can use to unlock those parts of the
application so by the end of the talk
we're going to implement a token based
authentication solution which
essentially behaves like this so our
users going to log in and when they hit
that login button we're going to send a
request over to the server which
verifies that we have an account that we
have the proper credentials to be
accessing the app and the protected
regions they're in and we're gonna the
server is going to respond back with a
response including that token we're
going to take that token and look at
putting it in our view acts state making
a copy of it and
putting it into our local storage and
then finally we're gonna also need to
put that token but put that key into our
Axios headers so that when we make API
calls out to the server the server can
essentially receive that token verify
that we indeed have the credentials and
then send us back that private
information and of course we don't want
to keep users logged in forever so we're
going to implement a log out solution
which effectively clears out all of that
user data cool so by the end of the talk
this is what we'll be implementing and
we're doing so with a very simple
example application which has three main
components or routes we've got one to
register our users one to log them in
and then we've got that dashboard which
again when it's created we're gonna make
an API call with Axios for that private
information but if you're not logged in
that's of course blocked cool so let's
get started and we'll start with a
register step and to really get started
we need to understand the client-server
communication here so we have a user
logging in as soon as they hit that
register button we're going to make a
call out to our register endpoint
sending along that form data so all that
user data then over on the server side
we have a few steps so first when to
check if the user already exists in our
database if not we're good to go we can
proceed to the second step which is
adding that user to our database and
that's about it in terms of the
essential steps for the registration
there's of course a number of other
steps you might want to implement and
also how many of you have using a web
application you've tried to register and
given all of your information
and then once you've registered they
then redirect you to a login page and
you have to re-enter all of that
information how many of you love that
user experience me too so we're going to
actually add on some login steps to the
register so that it's one quick process
in terms of user experience we register
and then we log them in as well so in
order to do that on the server we're
going to create the JWT token and then
send a response back which includes that
token then we can head back over to the
client side and then we've got several
steps here so we're going to store our
user data in our view act state store
copy that in local storage we're going
to add the token to our Axios header and
then of course redirect to our dashboard
so let's look at the code for
implementing this so here in our store
file our view X store we're gonna add
that register action and it is gonna
make a commitment a ssin so I'll pass
and commit as well as credentials that's
that form data the user information and
then we're going to go ahead and return
Axios you'll see why in just a moment
we're gonna make a post request out to
our register endpoint passing along the
user credentials and then when our
server responds we're gonna take that
response take that data and commit a
mutation we're about to write called set
user data and then pass in the data that
we got back from the server cool so now
we can head up and create our set user
data mutation that needs to take in the
state as well as the user data that we
got from the server and
we need to set the Buick state of our
user data to the data we passed in and
then like I mentioned we need to store a
copy in local storage so we'll set the
item by the name of user and we need to
json stringify it's because it's an
object and local storage receives
strings and then finally we need to add
that token to the Axios header so we'll
say axials default headers dot common
then authorization and then set it to
type bearer and then use some string
interpolation to add that token in cool
now we need to actually dispatch this
action we're going to dispatch it from
the component that contains our register
form so we'll head over to the register
user component and as you see at the top
here when it's submitted we're calling
the register method so we'll write that
out now
and again we're going to dispatch our
action by the name of register and it
needs those credentials which in this
case is the form data here so it's going
to be so the name is going to be this
name from our form email it's going to
be this dot email and then password this
dot password
cool and then when we get the response
successfully from the server we're going
to redirect our user to the dashboard
using the router all right so what
happens in terms of that dashboard kind
of looked at it earlier so when it's
created it's going to make an API call
sending along that token we on lock
effectively that private data and the
user sends it back and voila we've
registered and talked down those login
steps in the in the in so doing all
right so heading into the dashboard
component will add that created
lifecycle hook so we're going to make a
get request to the dashboard endpoint
and then when we get that response we'll
just take that response take that data
and then set it equal to our components
data so that we can then render it and
display it in the template so checking
this all out in the browser our user
creates their account and we've logged
them in and here it is at the dashboard
and I've got some fun animal themed
events because who doesn't want to go to
a puppy parade I know I would love to go
to one of those so so far we've looked
at the register component along with the
dashboard so let's look specifically at
the login component again to review we
kind of already did this in the register
but we need to do it separately as well
we need to verify that the user exists
in our database if we're good to go on
that front will then create that JWT
token and then send it along with the
response back to the client then on the
client it's really the same steps we
looked at
where we're storing the data in TX state
during the copy in local storage adding
it to Axios and redirecting to dashboard
so head back into the store and the
login action is going to be very very
similar to the register action so
similar I'm just going to copy this and
paste it here changing the end point to
the login end point great of course we
need to dispatch the login action from
the login user component which contains
that form when the form submitted we're
running this method which is as you
might imagine can be very similar to the
register method you wrote within our
register component so I will paste that
in change the action name that we're
dispatching to login we don't need the
name here in terms of our form data and
we are still redirecting to the
dashboard so checking this out in the
browser our user logs in with their
email and password and voila
they've been authenticated and
redirected into that private dashboard
like I said we don't want to keep our
users logged in forever and ever so we
need to implement some user logout
functionality so that we can clear the
state clear the local storage and
cleared out the Axios header as well
cool so back in our view X store we're
gonna add our logout action which is
going to commit and mutations we'll pass
that in we're going to now clear the
user data
so now we'll write that which is a
reversal of our set user data step so
we'll copy this and paste that so we can
then reverse that we need to
that the state our user state to
effectively know we no longer need to
pass that in either we're going to
remove the user from our local storage
and then clear out that
Axios header as well so this is this
works this is the effectively the
line-by-line necessary steps to log the
user out however there is a more
succinct and more scalable solution so
let's look at that right now so instead
of manually clearing the state and
manually clearing the Axios header we
can instead do a reload a location dot
reload and as you see in this tip here
this reloads the current page so the
view acts state and that Axios header
information it's not going to survive
that browser refresh so this is a nice
way to clear out that data you might
have as your application grows a lot of
UX modules and and it can get a little
complicated about where you're logging
out from so this is a very scalable
solution to achieve that all right so
checking all this out in the browser
we're gonna hit that logout button
that's going to clear out everything and
you should probably be returning from
your server a 401 because your user
doesn't have permission so great but
because they don't have permission we
probably shouldn't still allow them to
be accessing this route because they're
not gonna be receiving that information
anyways so there are some additional
authentication steps to consider to
really build out a solid solution so one
of those steps is to implement a route
guard for pages that require off such as
this dashboard so the user can't even
get to that page if they're not logged
in we also want to be caching and
displaying errors
the user might be trying to register
with an email that already exists or
logging in with the wrong password want
to catch and display those accordingly
and then there might be situations where
you want to keep your user logged in
let's say for 72 72 hours or something
like that so we can add a feature for
automatic login
I don't unfortunately have time to go
through all of those in detail but I do
look at how those are implemented in my
full token-based authentication course
over on view' mastery shameless
promotion here if you're unfamiliar with
kind of how the mastery works and what
that looks like we have effectively a
whole learning path that explores
different topics in the view ecosystem
so we release a new lesson every week
and we've got several instructors
working on different courses so our
subscribers get fresh new content every
week on those different topics and it
helps a few developers stay sharp with
their skills and relevant with
technologies since you're here I imagine
that you are a fan of view conferences
so I invite you to check out on the
mastery comm our conference page we've
got a bunch of different conferences
from all over the world with expert view
talks all of those are free for you to
consume so I invite you to check those
out and then we still over at the booth
have stickers unfortunately we ran out
of the paper cheat sheets but on the
master comm we do have PDF downloads of
the composition API cheat sheet of the
Knux Jas cheat sheet and then a
essentially an intro to view cheat sheet
as well so you can download all of those
and Greg let you know this yesterday but
I wanted to remind you if you are
considering becoming a subscriber and
supporting the view project in the
process you can use the code AMS 20/20
for a 30% discount on an animal
subscription and then if you are on a
team orally
the team we do offer team subscriptions
which are discounted so you can talk to
us at the booth or send us an email from
our website we'd happy we'd be happy to
set you up with one of those alright so
that is my time I thank you so much and
have a good rest of your conference see
you thank you so much Adam
that was fantastic as always